[Joe] Hi, you guys must be
new to town, right?
[Jenny] New to town, but
not new to the country.
We just moved from California.
Oh, we just wondered,
if you wouldn't mind,
if your daughter played
with our daughter?
[Mary] Audrey, say hi.
[Young Audrey] Do you
wanna play slide?
[Young Lolo] Mhmm!
♪
Slide's off limits
to ching chongs.
(gasps)
Fuck you!
(whimpering)
Do you wanna be best friends?
♪ Look at me, look at me,
look at me now ♪
[Lolo] Guess who's going
back to the motherland?
It's a big deal,
going to your birth country.
We used to talk about
it all the time
when we were little, remember?
[Lolo] Grand adventure to
find your birth mother.
[Mary] So proud of you.
Sandwich!
White people.
♪ Ya'll calling me crazy ♪
[Audrey]
Be my translator in Beijing.
Audrey, I got you.
Why don't you eat a dick?
Eat a big or a small one.
Whatever you like.
(laughing)
Kat lives there now.
[Lolo] Your famous
college roommate.
[Kat] You ready to lose
to a celebrity?
(slaps)
[Lolo] Deadeye's coming,
by the way.
Deadeye, your cousin?
-[Deadeye] Hey, Audrey.
-Oh, hi. Hey.
Deadeye!
[Kat] Where did that
come from?
You know I think I get it.
I called the adoption agency
and she lives in Haiqing.
Okay, will you guys
come with me?
Fuck yes, bitch!
I love a grand adventure.
♪
Oh, hi!
[Jess] So nice to see
an American.
- What do you do for work?
- Hmm?
[Deadeye] It's the cops.
They're doing a bag check.
[Jess] Fuck!
- Oh my God,
you're a drug dealer?
(screaming)
You're drug dealers
now, bitches!
[Lolo] What the fuck?!
Is that a condom?
We can't get caught
with drugs in China.
We'll get jailed... for life!
♪ Crazy, got 'em goin' crazy ♪
♪ None these bitches
gon' phase me ♪
I should have never
come to China!
[Audrey] People are always
thinking that
I have this perfect life.
I don't belong anywhere.
[Chao] If you do not
know where you come from,
how do you know who you are?
♪ Crazy, got 'em goin' crazy ♪
♪ like Jay-Z ♪
♪
[Audrey]
We could still find her.
Our passports are in my
suitcase, that got stolen.
You know who can bypass
airport security?
K-Pop stars.
Everyone remember their names?
Sassy.
Cutie.
Lisa.
Lisa 2.
I don't believe these
girls are singers.
[Xing Xing] Girls, show them.
Um...
What are we supposed to show?
You're a fan of Cardi B, right?
Yeah, but is she here?
♪ There's some whores
in this house. ♪
in this-- ♪
♪ Crazy, got 'em goin' crazy ♪
Kat, honey, you good?
Did you get the coke bags out?
Yeah, but only seven and
I think I put in eight.
Just push, pull,
I mean twist it!
It's not a Bop It,
it's my asshole!
♪ Hey hey ♪
♪ Y'all callin' me crazy ♪